[Music]
in ideas homeboys submitted by home
alien Costco Jamali in Costco yeah a
vegan called the police on her friends
who fed her chicken as a prank I bet you
called the police
they're both fucked-up [ __ ]
reaction to like a mean thing that
happened yeah that's almost like vegan
blasts her friend in the face after
being fed chicken and it's like maybe
you have to kill your that would be
extreme so this part cuz I don't know a
lot of people actually agreed with her
so this is the story unread it it's am I
the [ __ ] for going to the police over
a prank so she starts to preface this uh
kind of funny though my 24 year old
female and vegan and have been for a
good ten years I have not eaten meat
since I was roughly three to four years
old when I found out where meat comes
from parentheses spoiler alert there
were a lot of Tears this is this is we
get it this is no secret and everyone in
my life knows and respects this or so I
thought
four nights ago I was at a party and I
will admit I got white girl wasted my
friends thought it would be funny to
feed me chicken nuggets as a prank I
checked with them before chowing down
are these vegan to which my friends
replied yeah their son fed a type of
vegan chicken list chicken they tasted
they tasted off to me but I figured it
was just because I was drunk I was wrong
I found out the next day when my sister
sent me a message telling me to check my
friend snapchat story the story was them
showing the Nugget packaging and then
showing then showing them giving them to
me including the conversation where I
asked if it was vegan then
it's just like a Tressa mocking me and
pretending to be pretending to be me
when I found out I ate meat all their
[ __ ] yeah friends know things like
fake crying and yelling the chickens
I took a screen those are bullies yeah
what the spot and took a screen
recording of the video and took it to
the police on the grounds of food
tampering and now three of my ex friends
are facing charges okay they all think
that I'm overreacting to a harmless
prank so reddit am I the [ __ ] in my
view they took advantage of my drunken
state temper with my food and publicly
humiliated me I would have you it was
just a prank
yeah I would have just got him back I
would have [ __ ] spit in something or
it's harmless why are you overcome like
why you getting mad but she could
actually get really yeah where you can't
get sick from eating calm yeah if you're
a vegan you haven't had meat your body's
processing
she had been throwing up a lot the next
morning but she does admit that it could
have like a little headed like that
first it sounded like I'm calling the
cops but that seems like and also guess
what that's why you don't [ __ ]
bully people
yeah they hurt they've learned a lesson
the hard way
yeah but you bet your ass they're not
gonna be mean Oh a friend thing is like
like even if it was a mean prank and I
like gave you chicken afterwards be like
oh that was real chicken oh we got you
and then you're like oh no I feel bad
like oh sorry like it was just a prank
or what I'm so sorry like it was just a
prank
not like I'm doing it behind your back
and doing a snapchat thing and then
mocking you and while you're drunk and
throwing up over there that's [ __ ]
song shoulda gave him dog or something
like heard of them
yeah would he buy dog she's budget she's
vegan she why would she support them
well I don't know you probably have to
go to like Asia or someplace or
something
I've been expensive fresh yeah I do it
to get even I'll be like oh you wanna
laugh at me [ __ ]
after I've told you that sure I'm
getting charges I love what you're gonna
go against your own thing
how much is like contamination in charge
with them it's like a federal offence
because remember when they were doing
the licking the ice cream thing it was
huge boot camp going to the cops is it
fair for me like would that be enough
for you or no like I got my revenge no I
need them to be mentally traumatized so
they understand what it feels like you
should feed them human I made you eat
your parents see that's that's the way I
get even because it's weird part is like
you going going to the cops that's a
criminal offense but then when you have
an issue between friends I don't know if
anymore yeah they're not and you like
street like law you go by Street no I
want mentally traumatizing [ __ ] you [ __ ]
them up and leave the cops out of it the
[ __ ] out of them in the garage
they're just facing charges right it's
gonna go away tampering it's not nothing
is as satisfying as that and as good as
to traumatize south Kevin
but then one job huh what if it [ __ ]
with their job ah you're a bad person
reputation might be big they should have
thought about that what I'm saying for
him I'm saying for him like if because
for him he's like if they're not
traumatized but I'm like you could [ __ ]
up their life oh you mean the charge
yeah Oh gotcha I mean nothing is as life
[ __ ] as a trauma that they have - one
of the comments said cancel the
friendship but drop charges it's not
worth ruining someone's life over this
no like knowing dropped charges and
ruined their lives mentally so they live
with the fact that they did something
that's like a menu don't [ __ ] with this
how old are they
she says she's 24 I don't know or get
the thing that they don't like to eat
like oh they hate broccoli make them eat
it and you're like you ain't broccoli
yeah I'm about God's farce in its food
tampering either cuz it's not like at a
business where you're [ __ ] with people
it's like a personal space you know like
if I tell my mom I don't like onions and
she puts extra onions into my wherever
I'm making I'm not black food tampering
that's like yeah what's the definition
of food when she asked and she she asks
and they confirmed yes it is oh that's
true but it's still between two
non-consensual meat eating yeah but I
still beat you I love when it comes to
friends and family it's it's it's hard
for me to bring rules that are meant for
like outside Society in I think my mama
get off my property I told you this is
my property line if you go check with
the city you'll know at this longitude
side my mom like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about are we friends and family
or not I think the liability is like if
like if I have a peanut allergy
and I if I ask them like is there
peanuts in this and they know that
there's in it but then they want to see
me react yeah yeah I think I recently
saw something about like a kid that was
facing charges cuz he's trying to kill
like somebody we're not killed but like
they were trying to get what the teacher
I was like banana or something
yeah banana that's what I was but that's
like a song with a deadly weapon sure
hmm
I can't was trying to kill a teacher
well so like the teacher was like
deathly allergic to bananas and
the jofi a shoe because the girls not
deathly allergic to chicken it's a
preference what if that chicken gave her
some like meat virus cuz her body's not
immune to it and she died and you two
guys don't miss out on any more episodes
of just kidding so make sure that you
subscribe make sure you're subscribed so
you know all the details of bananas and
allergies so you don't get chickens
snuck into your food so people in red
are saying may support her that she's
not an [ __ ] for doing it the majority
of the people pretty much concluded like
she's not yeah you know they do little
thing it's not an [ __ ] I think if the
friends were like my bad apologised left
it at that
exactly and then she called the cops I
think she would have been an [ __ ] but
they didn't do that
yeah they actually post yeah yeah and I
think being mocked pushes people to
their limits
it's like [ __ ] I try to level with
you now it's revenge time and I go it
doesn't sound like she was there and
like called the cops at the party I
sounds like the next hit she saw it and
was like I'm gonna drive to the police
station and see what I can do about this
because I feel so vitally you know
apparently the cops saw that like there
was there was grounds for this because
they did perceive the video can we watch
man yes [ __ ] what kind of what kind of
people what kind of friends do people
young people need to learn that there's
consequences for bullying that's like
they're college kids Society yeah that's
when you make your mistakes like guess
what you Isis [ __ ] in college so like
these people get chicken felonies you
know wondering if I should face criminal
charges for all the mistakes that I've
made as a young person because of how
stupid I was
yeah you ended breaking and entering and
burglary those I agree with I pretty I'm
pretty sure those laws but then this
some of the other great area bullying
things like this right like it's like I
don't know isn't that a normal part of
being young and stupid and then like you
get you don't get you in these days
yeah in a village it's like when people
put okay what do you think about this
gray area when someone puts a drug in
your drink that you didn't know like you
know you didn't know you were drinking
drugs you didn't you thought you're
drinking a soda and they put ecstasy in
there whatever we see how'd you feel
just different though like in art when
when we were younger there's so much
more like gray area and like grace
period whereas now I think especially
with everyone having a specific identity
like I'm vegan then this is a huge
strike on them and it hurts them a lot
versus I think if we were in high school
everyone knew I didn't smoke but if they
snuck tobacco in my [ __ ] somehow or did
whatever like it was just it was there's
just so much more room for tolerance and
forgiveness back in those oh yeah if you
didn't smoke I would have smoked them
blew it in your face and make you look
like ya user you know just but oh
[ __ ] so much in these days yeah but
like didn't this day and age you know
the other thing is we didn't have social
media so it's like who cares we got TV
Millie ate it on that level maybe like a
couple your friends that were around you
sob Jo's blow smoke in your face but you
didn't get like thousands of people
seeing it on a public sphere like on
Reddit and now you're probably getting
written articles about it's like yeah
you can't be a dick now yeah I mean you
can if you're still in one of those
podunk towns that don't have a social
following but sure all that would ruin
people that's true but I don't know if I
want to be I don't know if I want to go
to jail for all the kid [ __ ] that I do
well good thing you didn't live in that
era yeah you probably doing it if you
were in this era then and you're seeing
it happen around you and you're seeing
the repercussions from all that [ __ ] I
wouldn't have that kind of brands use
you said you were gonna be that from
yeah you were the car I'd be the friend
that influenced other friends I probably
have the idea to give the vegan friend a
chicken nugget
that's so you should be an influencer
yeah he's still an influencer
I am an influencer oh there you go Oh
imagine that I just proposed I don't
know I'm just thinking about like all
the [ __ ] that I did that I should have
probably like gotten in trouble for but
it's like not a mark in my it's Karma
it's gonna come back to you don't you
worry your kids bro mm-hmm no but like
what like so I don't know you know even
even when we were younger like wedgies
were a thing or like you go like Bangkok
and they just hit you in the nuts for no
reason and then but nowadays all these
would be sexual harassment now you know
better yes you know the mental
repercussions you know all the things
that kind of have any mental
repercussions isn't it better like you
could make the argument like yeah you
know what that made me stronger like
that was just joking but like are we
trying to move forward as a society to
be better if something makes someone
feel better and not other people have
thick skin because everyone's different
than skin yeah like you're sensitive and
you don't need I'm just saying I'm just
saying we shouldn't brand kids so they
live with this for the rest of their
lives they're calling these people are
24 is like warriors pretty [ __ ]
stupid until they're 30 no way they're
[ __ ] stupid forever I still not
stupid [ __ ] 50 year old I'm still
stupid I know what pagers are
[Music]